you know who i think is one of the most
evil people on the planet is jack dorsey
i really do mean it especially having
talked to him a couple years ago and
we've had some chat back and forth on
twitter and twitter games and stuff
i think his whole
schtick is
doing dramatically evil things and then
you know putting up putting a layer of
you know covering it up and burying it
under some you know lie about wanting to
be better and and do the right thing and
how we're just so it's so hard for us
because he's got this statement he just
put out lydia pulled it up where he
talks about he says i do not celebrate
or feel pride in having to ban real
donald trump from twitter we're trying
so hard to to build a new system blah
blah blah i don't believe it i think
jack is completely self-centered he is
completely authoritarian he's one of the
worst possible iterate like versions of
this idea of i'm smarter than you and i
know it you poor stupid person so you
think he's like a modern uh robespierre
no not necessarily i mean robespierre
was psychotic he wasn't a first they
called him the uncorruptable
so yeah so you're saying when twitter
tweeted yesterday that they strongly
condemn internet shutdowns that are
quote
hugely harmful because they violate
basic human rights and the principles of
the hashtag open internet that they
weren't genuine and honest this is like
a psychological abuse where it's the ver
it's the sa it's it's a it is as if he
is punching you repeatedly in the
stomach while saying he's so sorry but
it's your own fault and for your own
good it is psychotic what jack has
consistently done for the past several
years promising roads to redemption and
decentralization and blockchain
technology we're gonna do all these
great things we're gonna help everybody
he is the spokesperson for gaslighting
duplicitousness and that's what he's
doing right now twitter nuked 70 000
accounts and they were not q anon
accounts one of them was carrie smith's
account unsafe spaces which was just an
intellectual dark web kind of
middle-of-the-road liberal anti-work
account there was also uh some some
podcasts that were center left but
anti-woke that got banned and then jack
comes out and says oh but we're trying
so hard no what he's doing to you is
smacking you across the face and then
he's saying it's for your own good why
do you make me do this to you and he
says it every single time and you keep
going back to him i i'm so sick of
twitter i'm uh i said it before i was
like i'm not gonna use it i started
using it again but i'm i really do mean
it that when i said i wasn't gonna use
twitter meaningfully any anymore i'm
gonna post whatever i i did it i did
whether i used to post my videos i used
to post articles i used to actively
engage now i've slowed all that down
i'll still post some articles here and
there i think are important but now i
just basically i've been trolling it's
really what i do i'll post something
like i you know i tweeted if history has
taught us anything it's always trust the
government to let us know about the
ongoing legislative legitimacy of all
these threats and to give up their power
and i just don't care anymore twitter is
a trash platform led by
extremely wealthy manipulative
authoritarians who think you are all too
stupid to run your own government and
and he knows you know what he can keep
doing this but i think people realize
that he's full of it that tweet about
uganda coming right after this election
where just a couple months ago twitter
blocked one of the most consequential
stories of this election to protect joe
biden the hunter biden story was blocked
and shut down the new york post was
suspended and then jack was like well it
was a really hard decision heck
materials shut up i've got active tweets
right now that are very serious
violations of the tw of twitter's rules
that are a threat to me and my family
they will not remove why and jack knows
me
because they are evil people who don't
care they are duplicitous authoritarians
i am sick of twitter man i'm sick of
reading about what jack is lying to
about this time meanwhile he's making
all this money and he doesn't actually
care to help anybody oh but you know
what they do these ultra wealthy people
use that extraction of resources like
everything that's been happening over
the past year they've extracted all of
our resources they love it and then what
do they do you get people like mackenzie
bezos dumping all of it into more
manipulative fundamentalist leftist
dogma and it's only it's going to keep
going now i'll tell you what the
solution is gab's got it gab's got it
right persuasion
it is it is about being resourceful
clever and doing hard work gab built
their own infrastructure
try and take them down they're going to
keep doing it
that's what you got to do the other
thing i think is when we talk about
politics being you know downstream from
culture and you you said how do you
solve that it's easy go further upstream
if someone is is taking a dump in your
water supply and you're like going to
get a bucket of water from the river and
there's like poop floating in it you got
to go further upstream to get your water
yeah max keiser says whoever has the
bitcoin makes the laws it was
clever in relation to who has the money
makes the laws but in the future it's
going to be the crypto yeah uh there's
there's talk about government regulated
like government coins like
cryptocurrency made by governments so
usdc well china just announced that
they're working on a global currency to
release for everyone out there so again
as we said cryptocurrency could be
something great could be something that
could be used to enslave a lot of people
to track trace and database people in a
very easy system now when you look at
twitter's announcement especially with
the q anon people they made sure to
specifically say not just q and on
people but q anon associated content
very vague very generalized language no
accountability no transparency no court
of law no reason given to individuals
hey why were you banned none of that and
at least if you're gonna do it at least
justify it at least give some recourse
give some reason give some explanation
but these people are so
emboldened that they're like we don't
even have to tell you why we're
destroying your livelihood we're
destroying your communications we're
destroying your way of life being able
to actually get your ideas out there to
the political discourse we don't have
churches anymore we don't have bars we
don't have any way to communicate and
talk to our fellow man except for
twitter they are the monopoly they are
the highway they control it they have a
toll booth and they are a
family-friendly show i i have other
language i want to use here but i'm
going to i'm just going to stop writing
polish no i don't think
i think you can actually be a bit more
disparaging and polish because they
they'd have to be like can we get
someone who knows polishing they're
gonna have to translate a whole bunch of
uh
i can't even say it but don't go over
the top but say something say criticize
him in polish
[Laughter]
one of the few words i know in polish i
think you said yes right it's hard to
control it because it's like it's like
in uh uh
what what what show was it where that
whenever lady get mad you start speaking
spanish she yelled at her husband you
remember that i don't remember what it
is whatever
also how they do these mass bannings is
quite insidious extremely insidious
because it's it shows you how you can't
separate the privacy issue from the
censorship issue it's because they know
so much about us that they can pinpoint
exactly who all the trump supporters are
on the platform but also think about
this they can also pinpoint who the
undecided voters are so imagine how
they're using that information in
addition to using the former to ban
people i'll tell you something funny um
there was you know donald trump posted
to youtube and they immediately took it
down and then suspect gave a strike and
suspended him so i saw people posting
about what trump had posted and they
were saying someone posted like i saw
the video it was crazy it was trump
saying like god calls on you to to come
and save this country in the 20th and i
was like what did donald trump post a
video that's crazy so i looked for it
couldn't find it
i eventually found a video claiming to
be the original video and that's what it
said it said this is the video and it
was like on the 20th you know god has
given you a calling and it was like
crazy stuff so i posted it in a group
chat with some other reporters and
personalities asking if anybody knew
what the video was some people are
saying this is it and do you know what
these other people saw it just said this
video this link has been removed due to
being suspicious
so they couldn't actually some people
could see it some people couldn't and
then it turns out the the rumor is right
now trump posted a snippet from his
speech his statements he made it at the
at the border wall so i don't know
exactly what that video was but even in
private messages they're banning things
i'll tell you one thing really funny
i often send myself things on on
facebook i'll use it as like a notepad
so if like if someone sends me a story
and i need to keep track of it or if i'm
looking at something to buy i'll like
just send it to myself and i recently
was looking at i sent myself a link to
like buy i don't know it's like a panini
press or something and then i went in my
messages and i was looking for the link
and then i noticed it said this has been
removed or whatever i sent it to myself
facebook went into my message to myself
as a reminder and removed what i was
trying to remind myself of and i don't
even know what it was
it was probably a link to bit shoot or
something it's kind of like we're in the
matrix in the movie we're on the ship
and we're talking to people in the
matrix and they're like i'm being
censored this matrix is censoring me and
you can't be like go use this other
matrix program in the matrix because
it's all in the matrix you have to leave
the matrix the proprietary software with
these
algorithms these proprietary algorithms
are tracking you
and they're they're they're moving you
around dude you know what's so annoying
we turned on we turned on the tv a
couple nights ago and there was a
commercial it's my tv and all we ever
watch is like family guy and we got a
puppy chow commercial yeah yeah
hold on i have not posted about the dog
i have not i've not posted anything
about dogs
luke got a dog yeah i i'm exploiting it
to the fullest extent on my instagram on
luke we are changing but but
why is it that my account on my tv when
i opened it up a commercial plate
because the tv heard the dog and i was
watching this
yeah but so they say that they're not
actually spying on audio and then it's
artificial intelligence that knows is it
possible that the the ai is so smart it
knew that yeah it's tracking luke it
knows that luke has a dog probably it's
right a new puppy also if you that's
what no you know what you're completely
right it probably saw that luke and i
are friends on facebook that we've
actually been in the same place the same
time you're on a show together and luke
went to a dog place and yep it's not so
much about knowing on a show it's about
the gps being identical and about us
being friends and about luke posting
about dogs well we went to that puppy
store that had that uh there it is that
dog that they were considering getting
and we never did we went to a a uh puppy
store and my phone probably logged the
uh
location and then they put a commercial
up for it there's a beautiful dog there
that we almost got by the way but we
didn't but there was also yeah
there was messages that i tried to send
you regarding defensive measures and
defensive stuff that i couldn't send to
you i remember trying to send you like
hey we should probably get this and then
the link never went through which just
shows you that it's not just it's not
just censorship it's also knowing
everything about you that that should
terrify someone because these companies
are getting more and more powerful
because data is becoming the new oil and
when we look at a lot of industries
they're absolutely dominated with
knowing who a customer is what they're
doing and with that power they could do
a lot of incredible things and i i
remember this even before
donald trump was on the political scene
that there was mainline data scientific
studies talking about how facebook and
google could rig elections this was even
before trump they were talking about how
they could just manipulate the algorithm
manipulate manipulate the search results
and they could have an effect on
elections that could sway it in either
direction that they chose it to go to
the ceo of reddit said it yeah he gave
an interview and he's like oh yeah we
could totally swing an election he's
like we we couldn't get away for it for
too long but we could totally do it and
there was discussion they probably did i
bet reddit tried to do that google
suddenly did it yeah but for a little
bit there was a discussion saying hey
this is too much power we should
regulate this we should stop it we
should intervene we should break up the
monopolies but that conversation lasted
for about five minutes and then it ended
and no one else even talked about it
after those data studies came out
because they block it yes they're like
oh no people are going to break us up
quick change dangle keys in front of
them on facebook
police very comfortable they feed you
nice steak that you think tastes good
they want you they want to keep you
inside and get make you rich
so you can exit them about rich you can
exit the matrix or you can ban the
matrix so can we talk for a moment about
how twitter somehow managed to make the
dictatorial government of uganda look
like the sympathetic party yeah
right yeah that's a good point that you
bring up here because the the tweet that
i referenced was specifically towards an
open internet but just for uganda not
for anyone else yeah i mean the argument
i think the ugandan government is using
which again these are brutal dictators
but the argument they're using is well
we don't want these companies coming and
interfering in our election banning our
government ministers from their accounts
and uh again brutal dictatorship but are
they wrong though because tech companies
are i think this is pretty well known
now they are arms off u.s influence
abroad think about oh i'll go back to
the facebook in fact one of the uh
probably for my favorite quote from the
book is
from a government insider who told me
that before trump the uh the state
department and the foreign policy elites
saw these tech platforms or social media
freedom as a means of achieving regime
change abroad by allowing dissidents to
speak by allowing uh information to get
out around the authority the the
government approved channels but as soon
as trump comes along
and brexit comes along and populism
comes along suddenly they start to worry
well uh oh our regime might get changed
it's not that what we've learned from
the statement on uganda was that
they like the idea of using social media
to control elections
that's it it's it's not it's not
inconsistent they don't want twitter to
be banned because they want to
manipulate the ugandan elections and
they want
they want twitter to be the monopoly in
the united states so they can manipulate
elections it's the same thing and the
timeline here matters because correct me
if i'm wrong it was first ugandan
government officials that were banned by
twitter and facebook then they decided
to shut down facebook and twitter and
now facebook and twitter are working
with the state department to bring back
social media into uganda and then we
also have to understand there's a lot of
also fingerprints with the state
department working with social media
when it comes to the arab spring when it
comes to ukraine and other very
important geopolitical battles that were
happening that i would argue the the
tech oligarchs and state department were
working for the favor of the us in many
of those key instances that do deserve
to be looked at right now so the way the
state department influence works uh is
you know they have the all these ngos
that they sent to countries and these
ngos are how they do political
organization uh they also you know fund
media outlets and so on and social media
allowed them to supercharge those
efforts inside whichever country they
were targeting that's why they like it
that's what got me uh booted from
venezuela some occupy activists on
twitter started tweeting at a bunch of
venezuelan personalities that i worked
for usaid and was in venezuela to
subvert and overthrow the revolution
that's what they said to overthrow the
revolution and i'm literally just some
dude who went from vice and i i chose to
like no one advice told me to do it i
said hey i want to go to venezuela and
they're like alright go for it that's an
interesting um perspective that if you
ban the matrix it doesn't necessarily
mean you're righteous like evil there's
can still be chaos and destruction in
the real world
in in the matrix world where on the
ships you know there can be
pirates and and dictators and things
like this ugandan dictator apparently i
don't know much about him um
so
the matrix is an evil it's just a
powerful tool yeah that happens to be
under the control of america which is
why ugandan dictators don't like it
and we say america but i mean what is
america at this point corporate uh
corporate banking billionaire elites
yeah that have like hijacked the us
military it's really not america they
just have control of our military i
really do think that
uh
it's almost like
they want to make sure there's a
permanent underclass that there's no
upward mobility like creating a new
royalty
they're the elites they're the ones who
get to walk freely in congress and and
through the capital they're the ones who
get special exemptions from the rules
and the law and things like this
and so everything they're doing with
destroying the economy
it results in certain jobs
become like you make certain individuals
making more and more money and it
results in the regular working-class
people being completely destroyed by it
and when the wealth of say your your
average you know middle american is
destroyed their chances of moving up and
improving their lives becomes zero
basically but the elites
who control assets don't lose that so so
think about this way
if you're rich
and you're worried about the economic
collapse it's real easy you put your
money into something you take you take a
bunch of your liquid you know assets
assets you buy hard assets you buy
property you buy resources you buy the
means of production then the
working-class people who have a small
savings need to buy food they can't
afford to put their money into something
safe
so they lose their wealth they lose
their access they lose control so it's
almost like the bottom's being pulled
out but the rich people have a bar to
hang on to and the people down below
don't they fall down well they've been
doing this they've been they've been
stealing from a lot of people through
the process of inflation and deflation
when the market is high they sell when
the market is low they uh
obviously buy up a bunch of goods and we
have to understand a lot of these people
a lot of these kind of whether it's the
federal reserve a lot of the bigger
banks they know what's going to happen
ahead of time because they're the ones
setting this policy and they could
decide i'm going to sell it all i'm
going to buy it all and they've been
doing this kind of system ever since we
got rid of the gold standard but but
what you need to understand is it's not
a conspiracy as though like a bunch of
bankers get together and go yeah we're
going to tank the market no what happens
is they'll put out their statement
saying here's when we think this will
happen here's what we're going to buy
and then all of the big banks make a
massive move which will drop the values
of certain things and then when people
panic sell because people just do they
buy it up case in point bitcoin recently
yeah fell down to 30 and it was funny it
was at like 31
and a bunch of people i saw uh you know
were tweeting at me saying things like
i'm gonna sell now and then buy back
when it's at the bottom and then within
a few hours it went right back up to 35
and i was like well if you sold you
screwed yourself yeah the the market cap
went from 1 trillion to 840 billion it
lost 160 billion dollars don't quote me
on the exact numbers so i think there
was a coordinated sell-off of 100
billion dollars but it's a bunch of
people made but it wasn't coordinated in
the sense that like a bunch of guys got
together it could have been it's it's
not
what you say definitely happens it may
have also been coordinated i don't know
it seemed very what happens is you have
a you have an avalanche you have all of
this it's piling up and then there are
people ready to buy at certain numbers
one person happens to hold a large
amount of coins because he's a miner
perhaps so it's a company they put it
all up for sale at at a certain price to
make all that money and then it causes
everything to just cast machines that
are watching and they'll trigger cells
and then what happens is it's human
psychology the regular people who have
invested what little they had panic and
then they sell it all and that's how the
wealth gets transferred to the wealthy
because people panic it's like this is
why i don't i love going to casinos we
recently went to a casino and i got man
it was amazing i put like 20 bucks down
on high card flush and won like 800
bucks and i started tipping like crazy
it was amazing i don't like playing
poker though you know why
because i i you know i used to i just
have a lot of fun playing poker to play
magic the gathering so if you're good at
like reading people then you'd be great
at poker but you're taking money from
poor people who don't know what they're
doing the same way dude yeah it's like
that you make money off the people not
the house i like playing against the
house i lose i go to casinos for fun i
don't go there to make money but i don't
like the idea of ripping off the
working-class people who don't know what
they're doing so i'm always advising
people you need to know what you're
doing you need to get sound advice don't
get it from me but just you know panic
is where they rip you off yeah and don't
listen to the mainstream media that was
telling you that bitcoin's dead it's
over it's never coming back and i've
been seeing those articles for years now
and i've been kind of you know combating
it in my own way but as we said on the
show a couple days ago again not
financial advice but it's usually not
the best thing to buy high and to sell
low that's what usually the average
person does it's it's not a good
strategy but when you look at the
mainstream media and they're talking
points that's what they tell you to do
i go to 4chan's biz board for my
financial advice
when you see lots of the pink whoa jacks
where they're all freaking out saying
the stonks are going down that's when
you buy stunks
you know i love this one article said
bitcoin investors could lose everything
i can't believe
it's like it's so obvious what that was
they were trying to scare new investors
into selling everything and it worked
and then the price dropped they they
bought high and then the price tanked
while they panicked and then the people
with access and means bought all of it
back up and now it's going right back up
to 40k i say it happens all the time so
i'm not going to tell you what you
should do or give you advice i'll tell
you what i'll do when i buy bitcoin i
just sit on it you're supposed to hold
hold on for dear life
but anyway i digress you know we got
into the bitcoin conversation again just
because it's been so prevalent the
reality is
consistently those with lots of money
can sit on it and protect it and use it
to grow their their resources and
control and power and everything we're
seeing with the lockdowns and everything
we're seeing with you know these these
uh these bailouts all it does is strip
what little the working class have and
you know the problem is many of these
people are cheering for it clapping
thunderous applause the wealthy are like
we want to steal all your money and they
go
yay and then they do
when you say like
go upstream from from uh
money if if you really want to solve
culture well you want to go upstream
from culture and i was like well the
rich people are what are controlling
culture upstream from that it led me to
crypto but what's what's above that is
is it steel mills no it's producing iron
mines and weapons it's producing culture
but what does that mean so if there are
if there are
if there's a stream of cultural issues
that ends with a political policy and
someone is throwing garbage in the river
then produce culture above them it's
like the strongest gorilla would is the
one who dictates the culture of the of
the tribe
i mean
kind of i guess i'm just saying that's
how it worked back in the day people
need to be persuasive and resourceful
you need to have access and means and
confidence and you do that by inspiring
and building culture
by teaching people to do things that are
fun but i'll tell you what really drives
one of one of the things that really
drives people is being cheered on by
others it feels good when you have a
crowd of people like clapping for you
people love it it's why skateboarding is
is so great you go to a skate park and
you don't got to be the best
skateboarder in the world but if people
see you maybe you've only been
skateboarding for a few months you
finally learned how to kickflip and
you're really bad at it kickflip is like
a basic trick for those i don't know you
could be at a park it's clear that
you're not that good and you're trying
as hard as you can to land this kickflip
when you finally do everyone will cheer
and clap for you it's not about you
being the best it's about you overcoming
yourself and doing better every day but
then if you are really really good you
go there you know when you skate and you
do well people cheer and clap for it's a
very positive environment some kids can
be nasty that's what we need
we need people who oppose the wokeness
and the creepy you know cancel culture
stuff
to mock it and make it desirable for
people to mock it to belittle it to have
a good time this is why comedy is so
powerful so we need more comedians like
ryan long for instance who routinely
rocks not mocks not just the left but
also the right on occasion making it fun
to say the extremism is stupid to make
it a point that you will be cheered for
and celebrated and successful if you
tell the crazy people to stop or you you
point out their absurdities and like
being an artist in general i think
is a great
way to control the culture but then the
money the rich people are gonna come to
you once you succeed and they're gonna
try and buy you out and it works well
not always but
it's it's very tempting
i don't know what you do with all that
money some of these people get some of
these these these big brands and the
sponsorships they've done i don't want
to name anybody but there's like you
know youtubers who have endorsed
political candidates
who like who are not political that's
like look i do news commentary in
politics so for me saying who i'm going
to vote for i think is on me but there
are like non-political youtubers who are
like i'm going to vote for hillary
clinton or whatever and it's like now
why are you doing that
there's no incentive for you to turn off
minecraft and start talking about
hillary clinton that makes no sense
that to me sounds like it was a paid
endorsement or something and that's when
you start getting into dangerous
territory but you know it is what it is
people are going to take sponsorships
for whatever and they're not going to
think twice about it well it's also it's
also quite profitable you want to win
the if you're not that political maybe
you just want to win the failure of the
elites at youtube or at these
entertainment companies because you know
the way to do that is the virtue signal
yep
yeah i'm you know i
i know that you know it's deep seated in
uh youtube and google this leftist this
woke stuff but i do think that there are
i think most people don't like it i
really really believe that's true the
problem is i think they're all just
terrified in their cowards
and and i'm sorry i'm not trying to be
mean but there's there's somebody who's
willing to say
i'll say what i want when i want and it
tends to be trump's boys are all getting
banned because they'll just say what
they want they don't care
and they're the people on the left
traditional liberals
they tell me behind the scenes all the
time i have business calls with people
who work for companies peripheral to
google or within google and they're like
we love your stuff man we completely
agree about this you know we're fans of
like george carlin and chappelle but oh
man i don't know i lose my job and i'm
like yeah you're a coward bro i think
you're right that it stems from fear
like um whether they're afraid because
they don't understand big the way that
technology works so the the unknown
creates like a fear of the unknown so
they just go along with it or they're
afraid or they're more viscerally afraid
of actually being banned themselves but
i think the fear of not understanding
how politics works how laws are written
how we should teach kids how to write
laws i think they care about that though
i think i think the concern is are the
people going to be mean to me it's just
very disempowering to not know to not
understand how the how the power
structure works i think they just don't
want to be fired they don't want to be
mobbed by the social justice warriors
well they know that if they get fired
for being anti-woke they're not going to
get a job ever again indeed so what grow
up the biggest polling error and i agree
with that they they should grow up i
mean you know uh people endured a lot
worse go work for veritas
for political activities but the biggest
polling error by far in the 2020
election was the white middle class not
the white working class
uh they actually predicted the white
working class vote pretty well the
pollsters but they missed the the white
middle-class vote by i think it was
about uh
over 20-point polling error really yes
it was it was massive it was the biggest
probably expect and what was the reality
they were expecting to be split pretty
evenly between uh uh biden and trump in
fact it was like over 20 points in favor
of trump from uh white middle-class uh
voters um
uh what was the middle no i think it was
actually employment so i don't quote me
on that was it was employment are they
in white collar jobs rather than blue
collagen oh okay okay right now and uh
that makes perfect sense to me because
the people in white collar jobs are most
afraid of the weakness
yeah because they'll
it's not it's not just that uh they will
take your job from you it's that they
will salt the earth to make sure you
could never have a job again
and that's what people are afraid of and
uh
really you know what man whatever
look i guess when you're you're
accustomed to a certain comforts it's
really easy to scare people into losing
all of it you know so they grow up and
they have this middle-class life and
they get a white-collar job and they got
their 401k and they get married they
have kids and they're like heaven forbid
i have to actually live like humans
lived 100 years ago it's scary i get it
you don't know how to survive on your
own anymore you don't know how to grow
your own food or hunt or anything like
that and it's not necessarily something
we should be doing we have this you know
wonderful technology and access but the
worst case scenario for getting fired
from a job for standing up for this is
not going to hunt and becoming a wild
man with your wild family it's literally
just getting a crummier job or something
or i don't know going and working for a
company that will let you work for them
but too many people are just scared
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live don't forget to subscribe hit the
like button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there thanks for hanging out and
we will see you all next time
you